early morning in the Bavarian Alps these
women have come up from written violent
a village in lavallee they say that when
they go rock climbing they put their
trust in God that's what I do believe
that God is someone who lovingly watches
over us and you can talk to him as he
went to a friend he knows exactly what
situation i'm in and how I feel even
when I don't put it into words in a few
weeks lagina grifhart will be making a
commitment for life this excursion into
the mountains is giving her time to
think about it we're telling the via
ferrata mitten vault we came up this
morning on the gondola this is where it
starts let's see what awaits us back
there how long will it take uh that
depends on our speed some do it in seven
hours will probably take longer let's
see
by the end of the day lagina is tired
but relaxed the climb was tough going
she goes off to get changed wearing
casual clothing is an exception she's
usually dressed in what might be
considered much more traditional garb
pagina grief hat is in fact sister maria
regina not a fully professed sister yet
but still a novice in a few weeks she'll
be taking her final vows committing
herself to spend the rest of her life in
this augustinian congregation we want to
document the weeks leading up to that
big day now 31 there was a time Regina
wanted a very different kind of life
rota Andy hi rod I wanted to get married
have children and live in a little house
somewhere in the countryside and have a
dog perhaps but then I realized I
couldn't shake the idea what idea yeah
gluten that I should enter a convent I
felt that God had a plan for me and was
perhaps waiting for me to put that plan
into action you didn't plan and he
taught him that sir
I'm not hubba code ask a doc and then I
thought no no way am I going to enter a
convent I want something totally
different in life but God didn't let up
I would almost say it was a bit of a
struggle I certainly took a long time to
reach a decision sister Regina joined
the Augustinian congregation of the
Blessed Virgin Mary in 2009 since then
she's been testing whether she suited to
this consecrated life the young woman
has been asking herself what exactly she
is looking for in the combination of
Prayer silence and social responsibility
and whether she's happy living according
to the Augustinian rule she discusses
those issues with sister be artists an
awkward mmhmm yeah it was liftin was
sister beata isn't just Regina's
rock-climbing companion she's also her
mother superior Emma option for lighter
from outer mmm dude lick off the office
isn't it like you know crystal eggy nada
yoga studio sister Regina has a degree
in theology so she came with a lot of
background knowledge but you don't study
the specifics of religious life at
University she had to be introduced to
the Augustinian way of life and to what
consecrated life means in practice what
obvious assessment in [ __ ] soo leave the
sisters take a vow of chastity that's
incomprehensible to most people in the
modern world the voluntary renunciation
of sex yet it's part of the reason why
the sisters where a voluminous habit to
hide their femininity considering that
the love between a man and a woman is
something beautiful and fulfilling it is
a sacrifice i'm making not being able to
establish my own family or have a
husband
but I tell myself that I haven't decided
against having a family I've decided for
life in a convent and that precludes the
option of having my own family it's not
as if we are forbidden to have any
physical contact with other people I'm
someone who really likes to be hugged
especially when I'm feeling low so it
can happen that a sense of longing
develops but is hard sometimes truthful
words from a young sister whose daily
routine is structured around prayer
times community prayer begins at six
each morning and ends in the evening at
quarter past nine each day's assisters
also attend Mass here in her convent in
the raw valley sister Regina lives
together with 12 other sisters the
eldest is 86
when she takes her final vows Regina
grief that will commit her life to the
congregation we had that once we promise
to live in poverty chastity and
obedience those are the three vowels
that characterize the consecrated life
in addition as augustinian sisters we
have a commitment to educate the young
because that was what the founders of
our congregation intended my own
vocation is to teach to pass on
knowledge to children and to try to give
an authentic witness in faith I can
combine these two aspects very
effectively here in the convent the
sisters run the school next door essence
Catholic High School has an excellent
reputation for the past two years sister
Regina has been teaching Spanish and
religion here but she's known the school
much longer she was a pupil here herself
that's when she first thought about the
possibility of joining the Augustinians
assaulters started offering hora at
libera weeks for students in senior high
school they gave us an opportunity to
look behind the scenes to learn about
how the sisters live how they organize
their community life how they pray
together what the convent looks like we
didn't know any of those things i took
part purely out of curiosity without
thinking i might one day enter the
convent myself lagina cliff had finished
high school in 2003 but she never lost
contact with the sisters Eppolito studio
Spanish I studied Spanish and religion
at the University of munster but I
maintained contact with the convent
during my vacation when I was studying
for my exams for instance or writing
papers I noticed how the structure of
convent life did me good rising early
because as a student you never get up
early and then going to bed early which
students don't do either and in between
those comforting breaks for community
prayer which run like a golden thread
throughout the day Susan I taxi
oh gosh luck sister Regina is now one of
three members of the community who teach
at the school some of her former
teachers are still on the staff did they
ever suspect that Regina would return
one day to enter the convent and teach
as emoticons everybody know mr. I'd be
making it up if I said anything
different another sister Regina was
lurking at leaf at a girl in my religion
class Lee puffed up I remember it was a
very lively group of excellent students
she participated in the religion class
without giving any indication of a
particular leaning on de leche de nada
cytosol Scott Etta once y cuantas he or
she could be stubborn sometimes once she
thought things through she stuck to her
opinions as I should walk to them thank
you dear diary kept direc- bought under
elephant Infante water given religion
for the 15 to 16 year olds the young
sister is of course dressed in her habit
when talking to the pupils she doesn't
pretend her decision to enter the
convent was easy they're very curious
and like to ask me about private issues
or how I view certain aspects of the
faith and it's probably good for them to
discover that a sister also has her
doubts and has difficulty accepting some
things and if she speaks quite openly
about them it's much more genuine for
the students than someone who presents
herself as a very saintly role model for
many years the Catholic High School was
exclusively for girls two years ago it
began admitting boys as well Regina
doesn't try to recruit girls for the
convent but inevitably her very presence
compels them to ask why does a young
woman in today's world want to join a
religious congregation it's finna some
globe I think it's incredibly
interesting that she lives a different
life that she renounced
certain things maybe she's able to view
her life everything that's going on
around her completely differently Sonia
massage don't want to we talked about it
in class what we think about it I said
that of course it seems incredible
somehow because i can't imagine entering
a convent myself for taking vows but
when you think about it it's really not
such an absurd idea justice what kind of
Zoar the ideas besides ago i'm sure
she's not the only sister i know hello I
know two sisters who don't wear a habit
they don't seem so unworldly so as well
of course when I tell other people that
I go to a convent school and we're
taught my sisters they say I did what
you taught by nuns aren't they really
strict Catholics the discussion in the
pews also covers very worldly topics
today they're talking about family and
friendship I knew my son wasn't i was
leaving
sister Regina explains that for her the
other sisters in the community are like
a family I enjoy the fact that when for
instance I come home to the convent
after school I passed through a door and
when I close it behind me there's peace
the cloistered area where the sisters
live is simple a stark contrast to the
hectic atmosphere in the world outside I
think there's a basic need in people to
always possess more to always want the
latest model in that respect life in a
convent is the absolute opposite we have
what we need to live and we don't
accumulate things we don't need that is
very liberating we are freed from the
compulsion to own things the vow of
poverty means renouncing personal
possessions sister Regina's salary as a
teacher belongs not to her but to the
community
Annika's invited if I need something it
would be paid for out of the community's
funds it doesn't matter how much an
individual sister contributes I don't
even know how much money comes from say
the pensions of various sisters that's
completely irrelevant this week some of
the high school students are guests in
the convent they can see at first hand
how the sisters live if I needed new
shoes for example I could go to sister
ate it and say I need new shoes then
she'd give me money and went for
instance we go on vacation were given
money to spend and we don't have to
account for it afterwards we can spend
it however we like whether we buy
ourselves an ice cream or go to the
movies it's up to us do you have any
special desires that you fulfill
regularly or perhaps occasionally at the
moment I would say that I'm perfectly
content I can't think of anything i
urgently need or I don't already have or
really want sister Regina has everything
she needs for her work in her room that
includes a computer and she also uses
social media at the attacker oven crew
and we had the convents open day I put a
few photos on Facebook so that people
could see what was happening here I also
post names day celebrations and
birthdays as well as sisters taking
their vows then people who know us and
even people who don't post
congratulations it's definitely a good
way of communicating even the eldest
sisters gathered for the group photo for
facebook vambran a second we explained
how it works and they have a pretty good
idea about it now I tell them what I've
posted and they show a lot of interest
even if they don't completely understand
it
almost every evening before night
prayers the sisters gather in their
recreation room to chat lagina claret is
the first new sister to join the
community in a long time this life in
community was one of the reasons she
wanted to enter the convent finally a
young voice in the choir that gives us a
real boost it encourages us to ask
ourselves anew am i living correctly as
a role model for her or must I make some
changes would I would still I give us
inland the community spends almost four
generations sometimes there are
conflicts and there's a chapter in the
rule on dealing with conflicts that
means that the people who wrote the rule
realized that it's impossible for people
to live together without conflicts
arising but we don't quarrel with each
other in front of other people those
involved in the conflict trying to find
a solution together despite the lack of
vacations there are still some 18,000
sisters in Germany but only about 70
young women a year who like lagina grave
hat want to test convent life as novices
the Senators via phone it's not as if
we're completely cut off from the world
we live right in the world in the middle
of a city and we have contact with
people through the school
a school trip to a climbing park it's
the first time the pupils have seen
their teacher without a habit they're
impressed by her performance on the
platform's 12 meters above the ground
I'm Isaac when you see her hair and her
forehead it's so unfamiliar I didn't
recognize her at first yeah yes we
thought she was another student she
looked just like us and she seems so
much younger
ok
after the excitement of the trip pagina
de fat is glad to return to the piece of
the convent she likes to take life at a
quieter pace the gay momentum at the
moment I'm happy and relaxed about the
next few weeks I have already made the
decision to take my final vows nothing
could change my mind right now however I
know from experience that there will
always be moments when I asked myself if
it isn't too much for me whether I can
persevere for an entire lifetime because
you never know what's going to happen
sister Regina keeps up with current
affairs by reading the newspapers she's
less fond of television because she has
a hearing disability in her personal
prayers she remembers the suffering and
problems she's read about
that's part of the Augustinian vacation
let's get too much we ought to move it
cut people can also mail us their
intentions then we include them in our
prayers for a month that way we can pray
on behalf of the world for me personally
prayer is a source of strength it means
that during the fixed times that we pray
I remember God several times a day in
the immediate preparations for her
lifelong commitment prayer has a special
significance for sister Regina just a
few weeks before she takes her final
vows she's traveling with her mother
superior the senior sister doesn't like
this official title she prefers to be
known simply as sister beata
video méxico moment I mr. it's vacation
time and that's good so I can relax but
it's a very tense time because I must
review my decision and prepare myself by
spending lots of time in prayer if I
sense that she wouldn't be happy in the
long run it would be right to advise her
to review her life once again self
critically to ask herself if she is
really suited to this life and is
prepared for it we don't content
ourselves was saying finally here's a
young sister and we want to hold on to
her that wouldn't be fair to the person
hi
Nick
names of me designers one good on her
return lagina Clifford meets two friends
from her university days all three women
have become teachers in spite of the
various directions their lives have
taken they've kept in contact her
friends have witnessed the process by
which the student lagina has become
sister Regina this much reassurance all
does does there but of course from my
own perspective as a young woman I can't
understand it completely we were
crossing a street in Munster once when
she had already entered the convent and
I saw the way that people looked at her
I also saw how some people made remarks
which wasn't exactly respectful and for
a moment I thought I'd a garbage fondle
it's a very difficult step that Regina
is taking a very courageous step which
side steps society as most people
understand it but to be no Regina and
have been part of this whole process
from the beginning until the time when
she took this decision you know that
there is no other possible way of life
for her and hymns and off kuvira me on a
douche embarrassment it was great when
people said I saw this coming it's right
for you somehow that was a reassurance
and there were many people who reacted
that way some of them were friends I
never expected to react like that but
there were also those who said you're
giving up your freedom of high hat off
those included Regina's parents they
declined to comment in front of the
camera but they're opposed to their
daughter's decision to enter a convent
it's very hard for them I'm an only
child that means they won't have any
grandchildren I think my mother also has
the problem that she herself attended a
convent school before the Second Vatican
Council or during the council when
convent life was a whole lot stricter
takata would have a medic on there were
bars on the windows and in the visitors
room and the sisters weren't allowed to
leave the convent I think she's still a
bit prejudiced by this image but I think
when you ask the sisters in our convent
they've all had similar experiences I
don't think there's a single sister here
whose parents immediately said yes and
to the convent we support you all of
them probably had problems but I think
that parents have to learn to let go
they want their children to be happy
this is my path in life and my parents
have to come to terms with that
eventually
the great day has arrived Holy Mass at
which a young woman will take her final
vows and consecrate her life a fairly
rare occurrence in modern-day Europe
this act of consecration is not a
slavish submission to rules but an act
of self surrender to God and lagina
Clifford's parents have come to the
church perhaps they'll reconcile
themselves to their only daughter's
decision now that it's irrevocable
Nimmo Canton has tightened another Irish
cannon tutorial and enough for the
kissing of those are the kinds cunent
the callers are not when a sister takes
her final vows the service is
reminiscent of a wedding and that's
deliberate traditionally she's described
as a bride of Christ
and as such sister Regina thinks it's
quite natural that she should commit
herself for life when a woman decides to
marry she commits herself until death do
us part basically it's the same kind of
existential choice
you